Our sixth principle, was knowledge-based AI agents make use of
recurring patterns in the problems that they solve.
These agents are likely to see similar problems over and over again and
make use of the underlying patterns behind these similar problems to solve them
more easily. We talked about this first with learning about recording cases.
Here we assumed that we had a library of cases, and
that the solution to a former case would be the exact solution to a new problem.
Ashok's example of tying shoe laces was similar to this.
When we tie our shoelaces, we aren't resolving the problem of tying our
shoelaces from scratch. Instead we're just taking the solution from an earlier
time when we tied our shoelaces and doing it again. We assumed that the solution
to the old problem will solve this new similar problem. In case-based reasoning,
however, we talked about how the exact solution to an old problem won't
always solve new problems. Instead sometimes we have to adapt an old problem.
Here we assumed that there were recurring patterns in the world that would help
us solve these new and novel problems based on previous experiences.
Even though the new experience is novel, the pattern is similar to a prior
experience. Analogical reasoning is very deeply rooted in this principle.
Here we explicitly talked about the idea of taking patterns from one problem,
abstracting them, and transferring them to a problem in a different domain.
Whereas in case-based reasoning, the pattern was within a domain,
here the pattern can span different domains.
In configuration, we assumed that the underlying design, the underlying plan for
a certain device or product was pretty similar each time. But there were certain
variables that had to be defined for an individual instance of that object.
In a chair example, the overall design of a chair is a recurring problem,
they all have legs, they all have seats, they all have backs, but
the individual details of a specific chair might differ. Now, it might be
tempting to think that this is actually at odds with the previous principal when
the knowledge-based AI agent's consult a novel problems. Here we're saying that
knowledge-based AI agents solve recurring problems based on recurring patterns,
but in fact these are not mutually exclusive. Knowledge-based AI agents
leverage recurring patterns in the world, but they do so in conjunction with
the other reasoning methods to allow them to also address novel problems.